french prince that was your very first
acting job you've never acted before
never actually so presumably you're
doing that thing of just
learning on set yes absolutely yeah that
was uh
i had you know i was very very focused
on being successful
so i learned the entire script and i
learned everybody else's line and i knew
everything about it
and if you watch like the first four or
five
episodes you can see i'm mouthing the
other people's lives
yeah be like like you said no way i'd be
like
and i was like oh my god but it's like
people nobody noticed
because psychologically you're looking
at the person who's talking
but it's terrible like i can't i can't
bear to watch it makes me want to go
back and watch them
but going even further back uh before
the acting before fresh prince
there was music there was music yes and
i was going through my record collection
only the other day oh no oh no tragedy
this is wow unbelievable this is 30
years old
that is 30 years old this is 30 years
old
how old are you here yeah i was 18
in that picture wow and like look at my
face like what am i trying to accomplish
you want your 11 o'clock sausage that's
what you need
because no because didn't you you you
had a hit record while you were still in
high school in high school yeah the the
uh
the single from this album is called uh
girls ain't nothing but trouble
and it's not true it's not true
but it was the it was the single that
came out and the last month i was in
high school so i was a i was a uh
a senior and had a record out for
probably about
30 days that is too much power for one
man to have
yeah it was that's awkward though like
when you're in a place
and like like djs think that's cool like
if you come in
and they put your song on it it just
makes you
just look stupid because you can't be
like whoa
so then you got to be like yeah yeah and
everybody's looking at you
like is he going to sing is he going to
sing
and it's like just it's an awkward
moment dj shouldn't do that cheers
cheers cheers you told me to mine my
head on the ark
i think they met me
now miranda because are you now you've
met julie before we
did a play together for the mouse trap
for a charity yeah just
but now have you met you haven't met
tiny before i haven't met you but i have
been
i've been you before you haven't i i was
wow how did that work out uh
very very well
i sang the rap bit uh to the jls song
yes yes yes yes yes yes do you remember
it
literally like that do you remember it
yeah please i remember
it was two years ago i remember
i didn't want to get out of bed if i
could rearrange the alphabet it would go
you
me jls b a to jfk to lax
yeah yeah there's a match mate got it
got me looking forward to it like a
saturday uh-huh tonight's bright
got my ray-bans on and my eyes wide shut
very good
i had to rap in the harry hill film i
found it it's really hard to
do yeah it's well that's why it's stuck
in my house it's so hard to learn
why are you pulling that tape no no no
i'm just laughing at that because i've
i've only seen clips like harry potter
but it does look very funny every clip
makes me laugh a lot we're seeing what
likes her
what's your wrap do you remember my rap
is about blackpools you'll give me fun
see you in sun
hot dog in a bun kiss me quick drink on
a spit
stick a paddle and a picnic if it um
[Applause]
you can go now you're redundant
you can learn
yeah that lady nearly lost it she was as
i was gonna i was going through listen
your credits
she was going say henry cavill
say henry campbell he's here look he's
right there
that's your life i'm just talking about
that isn't there a park where you go to
walk
yes yes there is someone um i haven't
seen this gentleman
ever so if you're watching please listen
up
um he does a lowest lane impression
whenever i'm walking my dog in the park
and he screams at the top of his voice
shouting help me save me superman save
me
and i've still never seen him yeah and
he's done it 20 25 times
like annoying but also quite funny yes
it's tough not to smile and uh and now
ruth look at you and your beefcake
sandwich yeah
because uh you know
there's something about my car these are
flowers they're flowers
sandwiches you've got two hunks
destroyed you it's as simple as that
rob the knight is young
we are old friends yes but henry
obviously you know
man of steel etc but rob rob
you have man of what well no but you
have an accolade
yes as a certain sort of man or where is
there a special honor in wales
oh i know where this is going yes the
western mail wasn't it
yes they have a thing in wales the the
sexiest the 50 sexiest men in wales
and shut up
this was about 10 years ago and i came
in at a very respectable
47.
wow okay i think we've got the uh the
article here
there you are where are you 47. look
you're looking so
sultry down just beside john humphreys
that's something when you say sexier
than john humphreys
only just gary
the secrecy thing how have you managed
to keep
i mean did they give you a script did
they give you a script
they gave me a script for about three
hours and waited on
you know out by their gate and uh so it
was a lot of pressure
to i just looked for my bits no idea
what context it was
nothing and i still don't know
so uh you know i uh i i don't know it
was awful but i told him
no no i i and i kept the secret so she's
so rubbish
she told me because i knew i'd do the
show one
day and it would help me and so i
i was the people talking about that
people be talking about star wars and
i'm thinking
i know what happens yes have you seen
the film yes
but before that a year ago she told me
yeah
[Laughter]
[Applause]
i love all the people to trust with the
secret i'm not the one
i thought you were a look yeah i know i
was very sure you developed you as a
person no but here's the thing
with this one is is he happy to stay
there
overexposed and he's tired okay
so he'll be fine should we ignore him
absolutely act like nothing happened
he's having a whale of a time
his back hurts a little bit
he is doing yoga i don't believe
his schedule but i know the thing is we
do know that he is a star wars fan
oh that's right we've seen some pictures
of gary because here's gary
and then who put the wig on him was that
you
i don't remember well somebody put a wig
on him
[Laughter]
that doesn't look good that's a great
holiday gift oh here's another rape if
you've got a cat you're thinking what
will i get my cat for christmas
you could you could do worse then get
your cat a lightsaber
have you seen the jedi cats oh my god
have you not seen jello cats curry
no oh there's actually if you google
jedi cats there are loads of these
videos
but this is our favorite video someone
goes to quite a lot of trouble to make
these
of uh of jedi cats here's some jedi cats
[Music]
now ben have we ruined your christmas
oh because i was told what my gift is
going to be by someone backstage yeah
our research was so good yes we found
out
what ben was getting for christmas and
then told him yeah
you guys are really good like i said
yeah no how did we find that out i have
no idea
i don't you know sometimes you talk
about stuff but this is something i told
my wife
christine who's backstage back in new
york a while back that i was
sort of interested in getting a
skateboard for christmas and
i like like an old one oh do you 49
well it's a vintage one from back when i
used to skateboard as a kid and it's
before they hovered it's just a win
and so i saw one on the on online on the
internet
and it's an old vintage one and i'd
mentioned it to her so it really
was going to be something that she was
going to surprise me with but it was
basically my idea in the first place
well you're getting it yeah yeah
ricky are you like do you do christmas
shopping do you is it presents for all
are you very generous
i hate christmas shopping i i do the
only
oh it's the only thing apart from sort
of animal cruelty that makes me want to
kill
i i don't i hate it i hated it before i
was famous
before i could afford anything i hate it
now when people look at me if i'm
buying what if i'm buying high-heeled
shoes from a girlfriend and they
they are for my girlfriend and people
just look at me funny do you know what i
mean so
i don't like it well now she knows what
she's getting
i'm so bad at one year i'd left it
really late
and i've got a big family lots of
brothers and sisters and nieces and
nephews and there's loads of them
like 40. and um i left at the last
minute and i got them all
scratch cards someone
some last it's lovely to see a 10 year
old girl one crying and one sort of
winning and going down the shops and
getting some more she was hooked
it's a life lesson i i can't stand it no
i see you've helped yourself to gifts
rebel um well
i think these were free so
are you going back to australia for
christmas i am yeah and it's
summer this time in australia so um
hopefully my mum's place doesn't have
fleas again
i come from a family of professional dog
showers so there's a lot of dogs
in and around the house and that comes
with fleas
i know and i'm like mom like you knew i
was coming why didn't you flee bomb the
whole house
um why didn't you just do it for herself
or for the dogs what sort of dogs are
they
beagles i know when you say like a lot
how many beagles are in the house
um like about ten wow yeah and do they
get presents at christmas
um yeah um but like not really good ones
because they're dogs and i don't even
think
if you have fleas what do fleas do to
you do they bite um they bite your legs
they suck your blood don't they yeah
really what a charmed life ben is led
one
yes they're not as bad as ticks and if
ticks like
it's getting a little brain i know what
ticks are ticks are bad
yeah there's lots of ticks in the bush
not in there no i know
she started
you